[موسيقى]
لا يسعني إلا أن
أنظر إلى كيغالي بعيون مختلفة بعد
26 عامًا من الإبادة الجماعية
هنا ، فهم حازمون إذا
عفت عن التورية التي
تنسج نسيجًا جديدًا لهذه المدينة
ومجتمعها ،
أعتقد أننا سنحتاج إلى ذلك الترحيب للتشغيل
الملابس
آه أعتقد أنني سأعطيك واحدة من
أقنعي لتوابل الأشياء ،
نعم أنت تبدو جيدة.
أفريقيا ، الألوان الملونة ، الشمع الذي
أقول إنها لقطات صندوقية ، شكرًا لك
بألوان زاهية جميلة جدًا ، نعم لإضفاء
إشراق صباحك ،
أحب اللون ، هذا لون رائع
على السطح ،
إنه متجر ملابس
جيد  القليل من هذا
مثل القليل من هذا لطيف ،
احصل على القليل من ذلك
ولكن مرة أخرى مثل الكثير هنا ، انظر إلى أبعد من ذلك ،
أعتقد أنه في كل مرة يرتدي فيها شخص ما
زيًا من هنا
في صالة العرض هذه ، سافر معها ، اذهب
إلى نيويورك أو
إلى لندن اذهب  إلى باريس يمكن أن الزي
الهاتف  la مختلفة قصة
رواندا صورة جديدة لرواندا
لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى سرد تلك القصة
وجوسلين مصممة على إعطائي
صورة جديدة نحيفة للغاية ولكن ليست نحيفة
[الموسيقى
] هنا ثم الطول الذي
أحب الملابس الجديدة فيه  عام
2012 عندما بدأت هذا هو الذي اخترناه
حتى أطلق على نفسي اسم علامة تجارية ، لم يكن
شيئًا تم
القيام به هنا ، انتهزت الفرصة لإنشاء
أشياء هنا في
رواندا ، صنعتها هنا في رواندا وبيعها
في السوق هنا في رواندا
عشرة  بعد سنوات وعشرات الموظفين في
وقت لاحق
أثبتت مخاطر jocelyn أنها مجدية ،
فإن العرض اليوم عشوائي يريد
نقله والذي
يريد أن يظهر أيضًا للكلمات
التي تبيعها ، أعتقد
أنها صورة العرض التي
رأيت  image لقد رأيت
الإبداع وطاقة الناس
ما هي الكلمة الوحيدة التي ستستخدمها
لوصف رواندا
أعتقد أن الكلمة التي يمكنني استخدامها
لوصف راندا ستكون turikumi
هي الكلمة التي تعني أننا معًا
نعمل معًا من خلال o  هدف جديد
نعمل معًا من أجل
بناء عشوائي نفخر به جميعًا